okay, so we've got to make up a little more
ground and reaching a million before Election
Day is actually on the table.
So after the absolutely disastrous interview
with Axios, says Jonathan Swane, which went
insta viral yesterday.
Even our clip, by the way, discussing the
Axios interview received nearly 600000 views
in the first 15 or so hours.
We've never had a clip go viral this quickly.
Donald Trump needed a gimme because that interview
went so poorly.
So he's down, but not out.
So what better opportunity is there for a
safe softball interview for the president
than to call into the sycophants at Fox and
Friends on Fox News?
Bright and early this morning?
Well, it didn't go well.
And because of all of the attention already
on Donald Trump's interviews in general, thanks
to that crazy, embarrassing, humiliating performance
on Monday night with Axios, people are even
seeing the Fox News interview barely had Trump
holding it together.
This was meant to be a softball interview
for the president.
And I want to look at some of the clips because
of all the top issues right now that we are
dealing with.
They all came up during this interview.
Trump on the wrong side, tragically, of every
single one of these issues.
I'm talking about Corona virus.
I'm talking about opening schools, vote by
mail, trump second term.
This is a Fox interview, and it went tragically
bad for Donald Trump.
Let's get right into it.
I predict you will be stunned and appalled.
So to start with, Donald Trump was given a
third opportunity to say, what are your priorities
if you get a second term?
And this is the third attempt from Donald
Trump to answer this question.
And he still could not name a single policy.
Mr. President, what is your second term agenda?
What are your top priorities?
I want to take where we left.
We had the greatest economy in the history
of the world.
We were better than any other country.
We were better than we were ever.
We never had anything like it.
This country, 160 million people working.
That before we've never even come close to
that best employment numbers, best unemployment
numbers for African-American, Asian-American
women, Hispanic, everybody.
The best numbers we've ever had, the best
stock market we've ever had, although we're
coming very close right now.
In fact, Nasdaq is already higher than that
number.
So a lot of good things are happening that
mystery jobs.
What I want to do is take it from that point
and then build it even better.
He still can't answer it.
Donald Trump got one chance at this question
during a town hall with Sean Hannity.
What are your second term priorities named?
Nothing.
Two weeks went by.
Trump got a second chance during a TV ad during
a phone interview with Sean Hannity, knowing
that his first answer was terrible.
Got a second chance at the same question.
Still couldn't name a single second term policy.
He now gets a third opportunity here and is
unable to list any policy.
He listed races and ethnicities.
That's true, but unable to list any actual
policy that would be a priority in the second
term.
Trump once again in his obsession to pretend
that the country is back to normal despite
another tragic.
Fifteen hundred deaths from Corona virus yesterday.
Fourteen seventy, something like that.
Trump says schools should open now and kids
are almost immune, which is, of course, not
true.
What is the latest on your view of how these
schools should reopen?
My view is the schools should open.
This thing's going away.
It will go away like things go away.
And my view is that schools should be open.
If you look at children, children are almost
there.
And I would almost say definitely, but almost
immune from this disease.
So few.
They've got stronger.
Hard to believe.
I don't know how you feel about it, but they're
much stronger immune systems than we do somehow
for this completely irresponsible.
Kids are kids are almost immune.
And I would say definitely immune.
He says that's wrong.
In fact, there is a recent study that found
that there was a summer camp.
I don't remember in which state, widely infected
summer camp.
And they grouped the infections by age bracket.
The younger the kids, the more likely they
were to be infected and carrying corona virus.
So, you know, it's funny to even frame this
question is what's your latest view on this,
Mr. President?
Because Trump has no idea he's the last person
who should be asked for his opinion on these
matters.
But he happens to get it completely wrong.
They keep going on coronavirus virus and Trump
again sites without any evidence that by Election
Day, Corona virus is going to be in really
good shape.
Brian Kilmeade presented Trump with the very
real circumstances that a lot of older folks,
the ones most at risk, are worried about voting
in person in November.
And Trump says, yeah, things are going to
be really good by November.
And of course, remember that Donald Trump
said in March that our fifteen cases would
soon be zero.
We are now about to hit five million cases
in the next couple of days to get the pandemic.
Seniors and those with underlying conditions
are most concerned about voting.
They could be the most patriotic person the
world.
But even your age bracket, Mr. President,
they're concerned about going out in a crowded
area and it's legitimate.
So having said that, what does the administration
plan on doing to make it easier?
More poll sites, clean teams making demand,
demanding more more places in in more areas,
providing the financing to do that.
So if we admit there's a pandemic and a hurdle,
what do you plan on doing at it if mail in
voting makes you unsettled, Brian?
All of those things and more, but all of those
things.
And remember, November 3rd is a long way.
That's a long way.
The numbers are coming down very rapidly in
Florida.
They're coming down in California.
They're coming down in Texas.
They're coming down those three places.
Shut up.
And those numbers are coming down.
So by the time we get there, will probably
be in very good shape.
But all of those things, cleanliness, they'll
wear the mask.
They'll do whatever they have to do.
But they want to vote.
We have people that really want to get out
and vote.
It's going to be very safe.
But by November 3rd, as you know, time was
eternity, frankly, as far as I'm concerned.
By the way, Trump says cases are down in Florida
and California.
We did a report on today's show already about
why that is.
Florida stopped testing on Thursday because
of the upcoming hurricane.
Say yes.
And California admitted today, yesterday that
they've been underreporting cases for days.
And Trump cites that as evidence that things
are getting better.
So that's wacky.
Let's now go into vote by mail.
The topic is the post office.
Somehow, Hillary Clinton becomes the topic.
Hillary Clinton accuses Trump of sabotaging
the post office or sabotaging.
I know some people prefer that which they
obviously are doing.
There's no question that when Trump appoints
Lewis the joy to run the post office as postmaster
general, the idea is sabotaged the post office.
And Trump doesn't deny it.
He just attacks Hillary Clinton.
Mr. President, thank you for joining us.
Mentioned the Postal Service, well, your former
opponent is out of the woods or tweeting from
the woods.
And this is part of what she said about the
pulser service and your treatment of it.
Hillary Clinton tweeting this, I fear Republican
sabotage of the U.S. Postal Service, including
slowing mail delivery, is a Trump strategy
to make voting more by mail more difficult
this fall.
Request your ballot and return them as early
as you can.
Your response to Hillary Clinton accusing
you of sabotaging the post office?
Well, first of all, you I remember the famous
question when she asked me whether or not
I would accept the results of the election.
You know, she felt pretty confident until
the end of that debate.
And frankly, she was very strong.
Would you accept the results of the election?
Well, she didn't accept the results.
She still has.
She's living in a cocoon.
And I guess people don't like her or somebody
doesn't like her.
But she was she didn't do the job.
She didn't do the job that she was supposed
to do.
And she should accept that.
Now, she continues to go on and she's talking
now about the Postal Service as well.
As you know, the Postal Service for 40 years
has had big problems and they're not equipped
to handle a governor where they see millions
of ballots, by the way, will be posted in
a couple of weeks.
Gear up.
You can't do that.
It doesn't work that way.
It's a very complex process.
So Nevada, we're in court.
We'll see how it works out.
But if it doesn't work out, you're not going
to know the November 3rd election results.
I'm talking for the country.
It could be for months and months.
I mean, actually could be for years because
you'll you'll never.
They said they plan to send these ballots
to everybody that's ever walked in the state
of Nevada.
It will be a disaster.
David Pakman.
Did you sabotaged the post office?
Listen, Hillary hasn't accepted the results
of 2016.
People don't like Hillary.
She didn't do the job.
The Postal Service has big problems.
They're not equipped to handle ballots.
You might not know the results for years.
None of that is true.
But there's no denial there from Donald Trump
that he's trying to sabotage the post office.
Hillary conceded the election on election
night.
Trump keeps repeating she hasn't accepted
the results.
He hasn't accepted the results.
He still thinks he didn't really lose the
popular vote.
She accepted the results on election night.
The Postal Service would be completely equipped
to deliver all of these ballots as long as
Trump doesn't sabotage it.
And, of course, it wouldn't take years to
know the election results.
But Donald Trump does not deny that he's trying
to sabotage the postal service because he's
trying to sabotage the Postal Service.
Hillary Clinton is exactly right.
Then the topic of the Republican National
Convention comes up.
Now, Trump already announced they're not going
to do the RNC in person in Florida.
It's just too dangerous.
That's the right decision.
Trump now says he might give his RNC speech
from the White House lawn, which would be
completely outrageous.
That's a political event.
You're not supposed to do political events
at the White House.
Trump doesn't care.
And listen to the reason he gives for doing
it at the White House.
There are reports that you're considering
possibly giving your convention acceptance
speech from the White House lawn.
What's what's the latest on what you'll be
doing for the convention?
Well, we're thinking about it.
It would be the easiest from the standpoint
of security.
You know, they move with a lot of people.
It's very expensive operation militarily and
and law enforcement wise, the Secret Service
is fantastic.
But, you know, it's a big deal.
And we're thinking about doing it from the
White House because there's no movement.
It's easy.
And I think it's a beautiful setting.
And we are thinking about that.
It's certainly one of the alternatives.
It's the easiest alternative.
I think it's a beautiful alternative.
I love the building.
I'm there right now.
I spent a lot of time here.
A lot of people didn't spend as much time.
I spend a lot of time here and I like it.
And I think it's a great place and great greatly
representative of our our nation.
So it would be by far the least expensive
from the country's standpoint, because it
really is.
It's a big deal when you get up and move all
of his apparatus.
I really hope that you understand why this
is crazy.
Trump now says, you know, it's expensive to
move me around.
Secret Service security, big mobilization,
taxpayer money.
So I might do the RNC speech at the White
House lawn.
Trump golfed 284 days so far during his presidency.
And every time they do, the full mobilization
of Secret Service.
And if Trump's staff, they rent every golf
card at Mara Lago or wherever Trump golfs,
it pours money into Trump's businesses.
And now suddenly, Trump is concerned with
not wasting taxpayer money on moving him around.
So he's going to give the speech from the
White House line, which is not a place where
political actions should be taking place.
You should be doing a convention speech in
a political setting, not on the White House
lawn.
But golfing 284 days is a fine reason to mobilize
Secret Service.
Trump doesn't want to spend your taxpayer
money, though, going somewhere else for the
convention speech.
The guy.
Can't even keep it together.
On Fox News.
I was thinking last night and this morning,
especially after seeing these clips, what's
FOX News going to look like on election night
if Donald Trump loses?
And, you know, never mind that.
What is Trump going to look like on election
night if Trump loses?
Fox News may be.
You know, we've been covering Fox News from
the from the perspective of its role in the
right wing media echo champ chamber for many
years.
What would be the impact on Fox News of a
Donald Trump loss if one were to happen?
I think it's an interesting question.
And we'll have more clips and coverage of
this bizarre Fox News interview on the David
Pakman show, Instagram page, The David Pakman
Show.
All
one word on Instagram.
Follow us there.